do we really know when the the serious
decline of the pandemic is is going to
be at this point and does it simply
depend on variance and vaccination
well i i was telling people in the
spring that by this fall
2021 it would be controlled in countries
that vaccinate 80 percent of the
population right and unfortunately we
haven't reached that in the u.s so we're
we're not controlling it and i think if
we get to that level of vaccination you
will control serious disease it doesn't
look like we're going to get there in
the u.s we might have to get there by by
some natural infection which is going to
take longer because you every cycle of
outbreaks doesn't get everyone infected
and you have to depend on another one if
we could vaccinate 80 of the population
by the spring of 2022 then yes the u.s
could control it but of course many
other countries will not be able to get
there so we're talking about a few more
years globally until we get most of the
human population vaccinated